una traslación que actúa en el plano
cartesiano lleva al punto menos 169 434
al punto menos 203
menos 68 cuáles son las coordenadas de
la imagen del punto 31 menos 529 bajo
esta traslación ok entonces para
responder esto vamos a pensar en cuál es
el cambio en x y cuál es el cambio en en
esta traslación así que comencemos con
el cambio en x el cambio en x pues por
definición lo que tengo que hacer es
tomar la coordenada x de mi punto final
es decir menos 203
unos 203 y restarle la coordenada x de
mi punto inicial que es menos 169
déjeme lo escriba si va a ser menos 203
menos
menos menos 169 menos 169
déjeme lo hago en amarillo
esto es lo mismo que menos 203
+ 169
y esto es lo mismo que cuanto esto es lo
mismo que 169 menos 203 sólo estoy
reescribiendo lo mismo
mi cerebro funciona mejor así esto es lo
mismo que menos 203 menos 169 y ahora sí
203 menos 169 cuánto es es 34
multiplicando por este menos me queda
menos 34
ese es nuestro cambio en x y qué hay de
el cambio en que el cambio en para estar
traslación va a ser pues ahora tengo que
tomar mi coordenada del punto final y
restarle la coordenada del punto inicial
así que va a ser menos 68 menos 68 menos
434 y esto cuánto es pues esto es lo
mismo que menos 400 34 menos 68 de nuevo
estoy solo reescribiendo factores al
menos y me queda menos 434 más 68 veamos
430 más 60 sería 490 y todavía tengo que
sumar 4 más 8 que son 12
eso me da 502
500 todos pero tengo este menos así que
me da menos 500 2
- 502 de modo que lo que hace mi
traslación es desplazar menos 34
unidades en la dirección x y menos 502
en la dirección y por lo tanto la imagen
de este punto del punto 31 menos 529 va
a ser cuanto pues lo voy a escribir así
va a ser voy a tomar este 31 31 y ahora
lo voy a desplazar 34 unidades 31 menos
y después voy a tomar el menos 529
y lo voy a desplazar menos 502 unidades
y cuánto es esto
cuánto es esto 31 34 eso está fácil eso
es menos 3
y menos 529 502 sería menos
en 2031 y esta sería la imagen de este
punto bajo esta traslación